before I'm ready to like [ __ ] fatten
myself up for Christmas yeah I'm gonna
gain a lot of weight on purpose I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna gain so much
weight I should eat and drink like a
[ __ ] on the holidays just don't
stop I I've become like no face in that
one
I've even seen that movie so I don't
even know what happened in that well
you've never seen Spirited Away no what
no
what
wait are you actually serious yeah I
like how you talked about that with such
confidence and familiarity I'm like oh
I've seen that [ __ ] my [ __ ] no
Facebook I've seen that gift like a
billion [ __ ] times have you actually
never seen it never seen it that's
shocking yeah for a long time I just
lied and said I did because I I because
I think I remember you saying you have
told me yeah probably probably because I
was just kind of like uh you know it's
like saying you haven't watched Death
Note right what the [ __ ] have you
watched Death Note you know it's like
what I just don't care too I've watched
nothing yeah I remember you saying you
have watched death yeah I just lied uh I
think one time we had a conversation
where you were like oh yeah Princess
Monarchy it's so dark yeah yeah but I've
never watched princess Monica either
have you seen any Ghibli films I've
never I've never watched My Neighbor
Totoro either is fine why is that the
one that because that's purely like
driven off Nostalgia the only Ghibli
film I've watched and this is within the
past five years I only watched as well
before that I hadn't even watched any it
was like uh Howl's Moving Castle oh yeah
that's good man and Kiki's Delivery so
service okay that was kind of mid
it's all right I like it so yeah I never
watched uh Spirited Away okay if you
like Hal's movie Castle you'll like
Spirited Away yeah I mean you like
hell's Moving Castle yeah I liked howl
okay how was the game
yeah yeah Christian Bell right that's
Christian Bale it's Christian Bale yes
Christian Bale [ __ ] off that's
Christians Christians oh [ __ ] he's the
goat man what can't
Christian male do I swear to God man he
does everything I love those moments
where you're just like talking about a
movie that you love and then someone
says like yeah did you know his voice by
that guy and he's just like
I had no idea that was Christian Bale
well it's a bit to be fair it's really
[ __ ] hard to tell he's so [ __ ]
good at disappearing into the character
yeah like I don't like he's a Welshman
right and I you can never tell that he's
a Welshman I swear he has like a
different accent everything I I think he
was born in Wales then immediately moved
to uh London I think or America he's got
a I remember he spoke about it once
right yeah I think he was born it's
funny though how so many people just
like yeah he's American right well I
mean he's so [ __ ] good at up here
yeah
yeah have you watched any uh have you
watched chainsaw man uh yeah I'm I'm uh
Nine episodes in oh my God I like it so
far it's it's a it's something man it's
I'm kind of glad that we finally got a
show that was hyped and so far has been
following through like I every episode
is a delight it's [ __ ] weird it's
just insane every episode is like a
movie budget it's it's a lot crazy the
fact that there's a different ending
every time as well like I it's kind of
insane I'm I am blown away it's just
[ __ ] sweating yeah yeah oh [ __ ] we're
gonna live up to that it's kind of crazy
even it's like I even if I wasn't a fan
of the show it's like you're watching it
you're like there's you just can't not
be amazed by it like if you don't enjoy
it it's [ __ ] insane yeah the story is
crude sometimes but that's I like it I
think it's fun I mean I I like it's it's
obviously a bit edgier than like a lot
for sure for sure it feels like edgy
yeah but I don't feel like it's like
edgy for the sake of being like edgy
like we see with like some other shows
you know where just like oh this is the
show that's aimed towards 15 year olds
that you know want to think they're
watching something adult no it's clearly
just like Fujimoto just being like I
don't give a [ __ ] if people like this or
not like this is just how I'm gonna make
my story and how I'm gonna make my
characters yeah yeah the I was kind of
amazed at one point episode nine the
episode before ends with the scene and
then they reused the scene in The Next
Episode but they reanimate it very
slightly entirely all over again and I'm
like okay now this is that's too much
that's just a waste like this is insane
but this is like what and it's all
insane animation like yeah it's it's
like I don't understand how how much
money or time power costing money again
I go and travel like I mean the amount
of time money and effort put into this
is must be another level like the amount
talent that must have gone into this is
insane what blows my mind is when you
know when people like look at something
and think good animation they think oh
the fight scene was like good or they
they think of the fight scene like
chainsaw man just looks good in like
everything the talking scenes oh my God
it's so [ __ ] every shot is so like
Dynamic right it's it's it's like you
know sometimes you watch an anime it's
just like always like oh basic shot for
shot for sure there's always that always
feels like there's some thought and to
put some thought put into how this like
how this looks on films like what angle
have we not put a camera at yet wait
let's do it let's do it from there like
I know you've read the Manga but you you
need to watch the anime I am watching it
oh you are watching it of course
I think I would actually be hung in
quartered anime is so good that I'm like
I really don't want to touch the manga
I'm like this this is what I'm saying I
know I bet it is but like watching the
anime I'm like there's nothing this
first season's only gonna end halfway so
probably probably yeah I think the
manga's as good as the anime I agree
I've been doing something like a little
quirky I've been watching uh watching
the anime then read in the manga oh okay
shut the [ __ ] up guys don't [ __ ] say
that [ __ ] [ __ ] what are you [ __ ] why
the [ __ ] could you do that why would you
do that why
um because why why did that because
anime is my medium of choice if I have a
choice um and the anime is doing an
amazing production but I think uh
tatsuki Fujimoto the mangaka is an
absolute [ __ ] genius I agree uh he
uses manga in a way that no other manga
artists I think has done he has such a
unique way of conveying like his ideas
and emotions and it's a way that is
impossible to replicate in any other
medium because he's able to draw it in a
way that looks and feels cinematic yeah
which I think is really hard to do in
the medium of manga like because you
know again it's like a lot like with a
lot of anime it's like you have your bog
standard like you know flow of panels
and like you know maybe every now and
then there'll be an artist they'll be
like Oh I'm gonna draw outside of the
panel like literally outside of the
panel to kind of add like Dynamic to it
but like fujimota just kind of draws it
in a way where it's just like
this flows in a really smooth way but
it's also a really strange feeling yeah
at the same time like now that I've like
read like what's been adapted so far and
uh in in the manga I'm like how the [ __ ]
does tatsuki Fujimoto have better
comedic timing in the manga which has no
comedic timing than in the anime right
it's he he's the job he's done with is
like the way he's like paneled and laid
out his page it like this the scenes in
among they're like some funny scenes
that are like way funnier I think in the
manga than in the anime
um and it's just because of the way that
he's kind of like timed it really well
with how like you turn the page and
stuff like you have any examples that
you might be able to think of um I can't
think of off the top of my head I just
wondering if you if you did yeah I think
there's there's a few things that I
think have like are impossible to
translate to the anime like one of one
thing I can think of is
um how can I say this without spoiling
anything that happens
so there is there is a weapon that
involves a nail right uh if if you've
what if you're like you you've nine I'm
on episode nine episode you should have
seen it then there's a there's a weapon
that involves a nail
maybe it's it's like it's like a demon
kind of thing right a nail as in this
nail
okay all right okay
no I haven't I don't know I don't oh
this nail oh I've used something that
involves this obviously something that
involves this
yeah you definitely have
have I yeah maybe did you think it was a
sword
maybe it was a sword
maybe you should I [ __ ] I don't know
all right okay we'll carry on yeah yeah
but uh there's a scene where he uses
this weapon
um and obviously it's a weapon that's
like infused with a demon right yeah so
there's this there's this like really
cool panel where
um like to use this weapon you have to
have a contract with a devil that's what
every that's what every weapon is right
and so how he portrays that this weapon
is controlled by this devil is that you
have you have like the normal panels and
that's how it is throughout the entire
manga every comic book and then when he
uses this well when it uses weapon the a
fingered just appears from that goes
from like outside of like the Box panels
right and so it kind of like flicks from
out of frame into frame and you're like
it's cool oh that's really [ __ ] cool
to be like oh there's something that's
being like called out from like outside
this world and [ __ ] like that and I'm
like you can't really do that in anime
because it's it's you know okay I don't
have boxes and [ __ ] like that but it's
like small things like that where he
really thinks about how do I like how do
I how do I do something that it's really
cool that only manga can do and he does
this in not just like me not just
chainsaw man but pretty much everything
I've read from him he does something
unique to manga that I've not seen
anywhere else
um and that's true especially if you've
not read like I would highly recommend
goodbye Arie which is like like in one
shot you can read that okay within like
that is it's so genius yeah and I was
like I've never I've never read
something that is just like so it's it's
a masterpiece in my mind so [ __ ]
genius yeah I mean yeah James I might
have loved it so far I think it yeah
it's it's crazy to see uh because again
we've had hyped up shows but I don't
think we've had a show that's been this
hyped up in so long I don't think I
don't think ever yeah and um yeah it's
insane to see it kind of meeting it and
kind of crushing it because it goes I
was a bit worried because I remember
watching like the first six episodes I'm
like this is cool but it's kind of like
your standard yeah standard affair right
now yeah from episode like five six
onwards it definitely got way more
excited yeah
um and it's been like so fun watching it
yeah but also I'm sad that I have to
wait every week uh I'm I'm sad that
we're gonna have to wait for a season
two yeah
um is the manga finished uh part one of
the manga is finished so he's currently
writing so he went on a little bit of a
break after part one and now he's
starting up part two again oh okay yeah
I did get a chuckle out of
I guess it's not really spoiler but like
at one point that like the name of a
demon is is means it's strength or
something and they're like what's what's
the scariest thing a chainsaw in a
garden I was like what I was like what
you have this like really intensely like
really edgy built up world and they're
like gun strong
I was like all right that stuff doesn't
really spoil anything it's just yeah
it's just funny even like I was like
what yeah
but things just get more and more
intense in the market it's already
pretty [ __ ] I've never watched the
show and actually said what the [ __ ] out
loud so many times like this [ __ ]
happens you're like God and the second
half of the manga is just like I believe
it I believe it's like the last two or
three volumes are just insane I'm just
like I don't what I'm I'm very happy I'm
very excited uh wait is it 12 episodes
they're doing or 12 episodes [ __ ] I know
I know about the 24th I know we make the
two call I'll take the same ending let's
just get a few more episodes in come on
that's like a whole episode of Animation
we can do come on let's get more
episodes I don't need the ending every
time the time yeah yeah I really hope we
don't have to wait too long for another
season because it's I think we are this
is
it's been a while since I've watched a
show and I'm like 12 up that's that's it
that's it 12 episodes I've never been
bricked up through the entire show like
that before yeah like from start to
finish like the food I'm like I'm Rock
Solid when they show food in the show
the food looks so good that's perfect
I've never been more [ __ ] bricked up
watching a hand-holding scene oh right
right oh Leaf [ __ ] man like talk about
like Awakening something I'm like I
thought this was a meme I thought hand
holding hands I was a meme man they
actually [ __ ] made it a thing dude
every character has awoke with something
you never wants yeah it's I've never I'm
impressed that they've managed to make a
character who is that horny likable I I
figured anyone that horny in real life
would would uh sorry in any show
normally if a character is just super
horny it's like like meliodas yeah I
[ __ ] hate them yeah they [ __ ] suck
but that's the thing that that's what
another thing with Fujimoto that I think
is genius is that like not just chainsaw
man but everything he's written every
character is an absolute piece of [ __ ]
yeah but he's somehow able to turn these
absolute [ __ ] detestable piece of
[ __ ] characters likable well it's like
in real in real life right most people
are gray like most people do bad things
so they do good things right so it's
like if you can kind of channel that and
I feel like that's where it's it's doing
that great like it so far changes man
all the characters don't feel like they
good bad it's like all right you know
they're again maybe they've got a lot of
problems maybe maybe they're a bad
person but they do some good things but
I've seen I've also seen a lot of anime
where they just like they try and make
like a like a purposeful like shitty
character right yeah like oh okay you
know all the all the edgy people are
gonna enjoy this one and then it just
ends up being extremely annoying yeah I
mean this could easily be like a Mirai
Nikki situation exactly it's like haha
Edge
everyone is shitty everyone 20 and we're
all gonna stab each other and it's like
all right well it's it's kind of like
it's I I think he strikes that perfect
balance where he pretty much every
character and change the mind it's kind
of like an [ __ ] yeah absolutely but
yeah it's like it's like an entertaining
[ __ ] because they're all trying to
survive right yeah so it's like you know
how would you act if you had to survive
yeah in this in this world that is very
[ __ ] up yeah like like just like I
remember the scene where they were all
like trapped in the building together oh
yeah just [ __ ] chaos and I was just
like I was just like it feels like
watching a scene from Always Sunny in
Philadelphia
yeah
because it was just like why am I having
such a good time just seeing these guys
try to survive it's it's
raining yeah they're in like a life and
death situation and they're just like
it's just [ __ ] bands man just when
Danger's like I'm going to sleep
last scene it's like bro it was that
scene where uh one of the girls like
freaking out and then I would just like
sucks like burst like full-on burst out
laughing and I was just like
it's just [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] riot so
good oh it's yeah it's been a long time
since I've been this excited for an
anime I just hope they don't give me a
reason to ever dislike the show so far
I'm pretty happy yeah to be honest nah I
mean even the second half as chaotic as
it gets like it's just so intense and
insane where it's just like of course
this is how it is and I think like the
like complaints about CG that I've seen
on Twitter
oh no dude there's like barely any CG
and then when it is it's like it's good
I think the most awkward looking shots
were like in episode one yeah and then
like they still use CG in like other
flies and it just they've managed to
blend it a lot better but even in
episode one it was like looked a bit
dodgy here and there like a few shots
but didn't look bad you know I've seen
bad CG I've seen Exxon
I've seen extra yeah